[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul aka peace taker because i
take the piece do you see what i'm
saying i take the piss and this video
we're breaking down the ending of
peacemaker from the intro to the end the
show has been a blast and the series
went out in style with the doctor of
thergonomics himself john cena at the
helm expertly crafted by james gunn who
followed directly on from the events of
suicide squad which released last year
throughout this video we're going to be
breaking down the entire show and
because of this there will be heavy
spoilers if you enjoy the video then
please smash the thumbs up button and
also don't forget to subscribe for
breakdowns like this every day without
the way thank you for clicking this now
let's get into peacemaker okay so first
up i want to do a quick recap of the
series but if you want to skip ahead to
just the ending then time codes will be
linked below now in suicide squad
peacemaker attempted to destroy any
evidence of staro's existence so as to
preserve the peace after killing rick
flag in a heartbreaking scene he was
taken out by bloodsport who's now not
the worst dad in the dceu i'm talking
about you white dragon mr t-1000 yeah
reich you're [ __ ] although it seemed
like he was killed the post-credits
scene revealed that peacemaker survived
and the series picked up on the other
side of this with a character recovering
in hospital harcourt and nakonamos were
sent in to watch him by amanda waller
and he soon got his first assignment
after the quarter maltese job chris was
approached by mern and the rest of his
sub team which included amanda wallace's
daughter tasked with taking down alien
parasites known as the butterflies we
followed the group as they attempted to
stop them along the way we also got
introduced to peacemakers race's father
the white dragon who's basically a white
supremacist iron man early on things
turned south when peacemaker
accidentally slept with a butterfly host
and he wound up having to kill her the
police showed up and they followed him
but after a little help from his friends
chris managed to get away to cover
things up economos stepped in but he got
a little too ahead of himself and he
switched chris's license plate and
fingerprints so that they belonged to
his dad augie was framed and he was then
put in jail over his son now on his
first proper mission peacemaker was sent
to take out royal and goff a u.s senator
who was suspected of being a butterfly
this was revealed to be true but
peacemaker got called beat and nurse's
ally vigilante stepped in in order to
finish the job cold feet more like
missing toes what now during this
mission they encountered judo master
lover of cheetos who's capable of moving
his organs about to protect his body
part now peacemaker captured gotham held
him captive throughout the series which
eventually led to another uprising that
sort of sets up the ending after another
bloody mission involving the butterflies
the big twist came when we discovered
that moon was actually one of them
adebayo worked this out using
peacemaker's x-ray helmet which is when
the truth about the creatures was
finally revealed we discovered that they
came from a dying planet in search of a
new home and goth's butterfly wanted to
take over the year moon's butterfly
basically dissented and he then took
over the worst person he could find
clemson man meanwhile detective song
released peacemakers farther leading him
to want to get revenge on his own son we
eventually learned that chris and his
brother were forced to fight in bare
knuckle boxing matches for their dad's
entertainment which does sort of explain
a lot of their relationship during one
of the bouts chris accidentally killed
his brother and since then his father
has blamed him instead of taking
responsibility he ended up donning his
white dragon armor and he set out to
kill his son which we'll talk about in
just a bit on the other side of this the
police ended up going after vigilante
and peacemaker who managed to escape but
during this time goth was freed in the
body of detective song it took over the
police force including wallace plant
lock he was supposed to help the mission
but he exposed peacemaker instead and it
led to all eyes on him sung also killed
mirn and crushed the butterfly which
then mothballed the team's plans thank
you thank you i'm here all week a white
dragon went after him too but chris
managed to overpower his dad and he
killed him which left just the butterfly
threat during the last episode the team
were able to locate where the
butterfly's food source was kept and
they went to take out this cow the
butterflies were attempting to teleport
it out and early on the episode somewhat
becomes a mission against time to try
and track it down they end up defeating
the cow on the end but we'll talk about
that later on in the video now in the
finale we meet the justice league who
arrive in the aftermath of the battle
aquaman and flash make major cameos and
alongside them are superman and wonder
woman at the moment henry cavill is
pretty much shrouding his supes as we
don't know whether he's in or out of the
dc eu there's been a lot of back and
forth behind the scenes from what i've
heard and the rumors about things being
a still mate could be true they do keep
him in shadow however the same thing is
done with wonder woman so this may be a
case of the show not having the budget
to bring the actors in without it
spiraling out of control i can imagine
that supes being in the shadows will
annoy a lot of people who want to see
henry cavill back and for whatever
reason he's kept in the dark as much as
we are now aquaman appearing of course
plays off a big joke from the first
episode in which chris said that he
[ __ ] fish by which yeah the jury is
still out probably better than amber
turd in the bed though now there's also
flash there too who will of course be
appearing in his own solo movie this
year it looks like the film will be
based heavily on flashpoint and it'll
have him going back to save his mother
from being murdered this will create a
branch timeline in which michael keaton
will be batman instead of ben affleck
interestingly there's no batman in the
justice league and though he did get
name dropped earlier in the season we do
know things are a bit up in the air with
him too in addition to affleck and
keaton appearing in the flash we also
have robert pattinson showing up as the
character next month in his own separate
universe so perhaps they just didn't
want to get people too confused on top
of this cyborg is also missing from the
lineup ray fisher very publicly has
talked about the harassment and erasure
that he had by wb and yeah i think they
should have included him in this lineup
even if it was in shadow like the others
we know rey is very much done with the
dc eu though so it's quite complicated
over whether they should have included
the character without his blessing and
i'd love to hear your opinion on the
situation below i don't want to get too
deep into it as i could spend all day
talking about it but the cameos are
definitely one of the high points of the
episode parkour ends have been hospital
paralyzed which somewhat mirrors the way
that chris started off at the beginning
of the series it's quite a bit of sweet
ending and yesterday before the finale
released it was announced that john cena
will be back for season 2. james gunn
will once more be behind the show and
we'll theorize what's going on with that
later in the video now we start off the
entry with the group riding out of the
cow with the song steel panther if you
really love me playing in the background
they approach the camp and assemble the
helmets some of which are named after
the rock albums and just as for all in
sonic boom by metallica and kiss
respectively and justice for all is
scabies for all and i love the little
easter eggs lace throughout the show
this isn't really an easter egg
breakdown but yeah i thought i'd bring
them up because they're pretty niche
green arrow is confirmed in the dc eu
and eagerly doesn't eagerly approach the
base he ends up dropping one of the
helmets in the forest and when looking
for it chris comes across a
hallucination of his father which he
kills in his imagination he hits him in
the same spot that he did to kill him in
real life and come the end of the entry
his father still clearly haunts him now
i think that this confirms robert
patrick will be back for season 2 and
that he'll very much be at the
character's side taunting him this is
something that the joker did in arkham
knight and it works really well allowing
the vision to embody all the characters
doubts though early on he talks about
his brother's death and somewhat comes
to terms with him not being guilty over
it it's clear he still resents himself
since then he's murdered people in the
name of peace but his father appearing
once more shows the guilt that he
somewhat feels over killing him i'm not
a psychologist yet but i think that the
whole point of peacemaker is that he
finally internalizes his mistakes and
tries to learn from them he's even down
to kill his father's vision but come the
end of the entry he lets out one live
showing that he's likely on the right
path to growing as a person and tackling
his inner demons perhaps he will keep
his father around until he's completely
dealt with all the trauma he caused and
i think that would be a really
interesting way to take season two now
oconomous manages to sneak into the base
using a stolen uniform and a bag with a
sonic boom helmet in it his question and
acts really weird over it but he's let
in for an unknown reason i actually
think this is because he acts really
weirdly and as butterflies act weird
they think that it's normal might be a
reach but we get some more nods to other
moments with the character when seeing
the cow he panics and leaves saying no
more kaijus this is a callback to
suicide squad when he called staro the
conqueror a kaiju as well he's also
asked about his beard which is a nod to
peacemaker calling him die beard after
admitting his insecurities economos is
caught and the butterflies start to
chase him down however the sonic boom
helmet saves the day with a repeat
activation of it slowly destroying the
lair with the charges depleted the group
head into the rubble leaving adebayo
behind peacemaker takes his shield and
when discussing the character gunners
often referenced how he's basically a
twisted version of captain america the
poster for the show even looked
extremely similar to an old image of
captain america and it's nice that this
is included after going all out on the
butterflies chris stumbles inside the
lair but both harcourt and vigilante are
shot on the outside seeing the
destruction and a buyer runs in and
shows exactly why she's amanda wallace's
daughter she saves harcourt from being
taken over and goes after chris with a
torpedo helmet trapped under rubble goth
in the body of song pulls him out and
beats the crap out of him goth goes
somewhat on a social commentary tangent
and says that the butterflies very much
recognize the failings of their own
planet in our own there's clear
allusions to climate change the pandemic
and how profit is often put above people
goth recognizes the good and chris
because of how he cared and the
butterfly says that he can be the
peacemaker that he's always wanted to be
instead though he activates the human
torpedo helmet which sends adebayo
flying into the cow killing it in the
process peacemaker kills lock and shoots
goth but he allows the butterfly to live
again a peacemaker refusing to destroy
lives in the name of peace brings his
character full circle and throughout the
season we've seen as he's been filled
with regret over his actions in the
movie suicide squad the guy knew deep
down that he didn't do the right thing
and though he's kept up with his image
of bravado he finally drops it and
allows humanity to continue making their
own mistakes instead of being enslaved
on the outside he runs into the justice
league and flash says it he [ __ ] fish
man in a rumor now hawk and vigilante
are dropped off at the hospital and
adebayo and chris have a heart to heart
in many ways the pair mirror one another
and they were of course put on a path by
their parents to follow them in their
footsteps both kind of showed that they
were more than that and that they can
make their own choices which was
reflected in chris putting an end to
goff's plan the notes on operation
butterfly are exposed to the public by
adebayo along with the truth about chris
and his fake diary task force x is
brought to light which brings them into
the public eye for years task force x
has used criminals on black ops missions
and walla will now have to deal with not
only the fallout from her own daughter
but also the public who are now aware of
the operations she returns to her wife
putting her above the job and harcourt
recovers in the hospital with chris by
his side economist returns to believe as
a member of staff and though he's back
behind the desk he remembers the fun he
had with his friends judo master surveys
the carnage and in the woods vigilante
and chris have some fun whilst harcourt
teaches herself to walk again now the
final scene deals with goth coming back
to chris and rather than being placed in
a jar he's now alongside it showing
somewhat inner peace with peacemaker
peacemaker is now a peacemaker with the
butterflies and he's joined by a vision
of his father once more we end the
season with him laughing showing that
the character might have to come to
grips with all that we discussed earlier
it's a great way to close out the season
and i think going forward goth might
somewhat become an ally to peacemaker as
they tackle more intergalactic threats
with task force x now being the public
eye there'll also likely be a debate
over whether its existence should be a
thing or not i can actually see there
being a for and against argument and
chris might be brought back into a
mission but i think he'll have more free
will at this point rather than being
forced to do it it sends the series out
on a high and the post credits seen as
an extended moment with vigilante saying
to economist he's worried that he's
gonna die that closes things off and
sets up season two which i'll keep you
updated on as we get more info now as
for my thoughts on the series i have to
say i've had an absolute blast with
peacemaker and it's been my favorite
show of the so4 i think it's done the
action drama and comedy really well and
john cena has nailed everything in front
of him when they inevitably do a
terminator reboot i'd love to see him
play the robot machine as i think the
guy is built like a brick [ __ ] house but
he's also able to do the friendly and
more charismatic things that arnie
pulled off don't know why i said robot
machine and we're veering completely off
subject there but i think with him at
the helm that the show's really excelled
james gunn is also extremely talented
when it comes to team ups and after
guardians suicide squad and this i can't
wait to see what he does next the guy is
a great writer and i don't really have
anything bad to say about how it was
paced directed or written even the intro
is so good that it's something you just
can't skip and it's been the show that
i'm most excited for every single week i
don't really have anything bad to say
and though it's very juvenile humor you
can probably guess that's right up my
street and for me peacemaker was a
complete blast from beginning to end the
next dc project coming out is the batman
and the company has a really solid year
by the looks of it overall i'm sure you
can guess i love the show and because of
that it gets a 9 out of 10. i'd of
course love to hear your thoughts so
make sure you comment below and let me
know we're running a competition right
now and giving away three copies of the
june box set on the 28th of feb and all
you have to do to be on the chance of
winning is like the video make sure you
subscribe with notifications on and
trouble comment below with your thoughts
on the finale if you pick the comments
at random at the end of the month and
the winners of the last one are on
screen right now so if that's you then
message me on twitter at heavyspoilers
if you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our breakdown of
the doctor strange trailer which will be
linked on screen right now we go over
all the easter eggs in it and give our
theories on what could be happening in
the movie so definitely go check it out
right after this without the way thank
you for seeing through the video i've
been paul and i'll see you next time
take care peace maker